i think people are afraid to go like you
think about the normal spring break
destinations cancun maybe ibiza i know
i'm saying it wrong it's supposed to be
ibiza
but uh maybe people are afraid to travel
internationally now
because of health stuff so maybe that
means everyone's just gonna stay
domestic and then go to florida
yes which brings him to we'll jump over
the next story on this one because this
is how crazy things have gotten with
kovid so
when you when you see what's happening
in miami and this insanity
i'm not surprised that people are doing
crazy stuff because people kind of lost
their minds over the past year
i'm sure most people who are listening
to this can probably relate in some way
to how
awful the lockdowns were i immediately
got out of the city i went to the middle
of nowhere well not immediately i mean i
was in the suburbs already so things
weren't that bad
and then we went out to the middle of
nowhere where things are fantastic
you ask somebody who lives in the middle
of nowhere how is the lock down ben
lobeck haven't noticed
check this out we got this from
express.co.uk
holidays overseas to be made illegal
five thousand pound fine for people
trying to leave britain
if you if you if you're in britain and
you try to leave
they will fine you five thousand pounds
which is basically like seven
grand damn yeah yeah so i'm i'm glad i
don't live there
but i can imagine people are gonna start
going crazy like you know
you know what's really crazy about the
story is the uk is basically now the
plot of v for vendetta
like almost vendetta plot is i saw it so
long
yes sam so it's basically and again i'm
explaining the plot for v for vendetta i
am not
asserting any conspiracy theories about
covet v for vendetta
is about these like corrupt politicians
and
and and you know crony corporate types
who
manufacture a virus to use as a pretext
to gain authoritarian control of the
country interesting so i'm not saying
that's literally what happened in the uk
i'm saying it's
it's making people say that because you
get the pandemic which affected
everybody
and then you get you the uk
like they arrest people for jokes now if
you try to leave
5 000 pounds what if you're just sick of
the weather you know what if you're like
can't leave i've had it i'm going to fix
my teeth
let me get it we're all in this together
chrissy you can't leave
dang this is the crazy thing too because
i've been hitting up people like
you know i hit up count dankula and i
hit up carl benjamin i'm like yo
when can we get you out here things are
starting to improve over here
across the pond and they're like if we
try and leave we'll be like arrested and
fined
they could just scary get five and then
what happens if you don't pay the fine
i imagine they'll like maybe like dank
it'll just take it from your bank
account or they'll arrest you or
something
god i don't know get a disguise well no
how you supposed to leave
you you go to the airport and they used
to arrest you check this out from the
telegraph
people caught without a reasonable
excuse for travel will be in breach of
regulations
from march 29th under new roadmap rules
you got a week oh man you got a week to
leave i was going to say get out while
you still can but i don't want to
i don't want to push anyone look at this
oh it's for spring break
yeah they call it easter break number 10
indicated the 5 000
fine was designed to deter anyone
thinking of going abroad for an easter
break in defiance of the ban
on foreign travel it will apply to both
britons and european citizens living in
the uk
amid fears that anyone going abroad for
a holiday or family reunion
could import new covet variants on their
return the only exemptions for to the
travel ban are for work study moving
house
or attending a major family event which
is a birth wedding or funeral i mean
that's
kind of a lot of exceptions to be honest
does it say anything about twerking
uh if you just got it actually that is
allowed okay yes if they catch you in
the airport twerking they will not find
you
right they must be going to miami go to
miami all right that's fine
they are part of the government's new
regulations enacting boris johnson's
roadmap
out of lockdown and laid in parliament
on monday they state that no one may
leave england to travel to a destination
outside the united kingdom
or travel to or be present at an
embarkation point for the purpose of
traveling from there to a destination
outside the united kingdom
without a reasonable excuse so like i
guess you could literally be in the
airport
and they could stop you back while
you're traveling and you're like
for fun you're under arrest really is
the meme about needing a license for
everything
you know in the uk the joke is that in
the uk you need a license for everything
you do
jesus man i wanna i don't to
dump on people that are british citizens
i feel bad for those people well there's
called subjects
which is crazy british subjects
like are they citizens are they subjects
or is that are they both what the heck
they're a subject yeah that's right to
someone what's so crazy
this is really amazing to watch happen
to be honest because we've we've had it
pretty bad in in the us
with the draconian lockdown stuff but i
mean wow
you can't even leave it puts it into
perspective and i read somewhere that
you can't even leave your house in
france without like a
paper i don't know if you take a note
from your doctor i don't know you need
some kind of proof that you're supposed
to be out of your house
and apparently i think in greece you
have to text the cops
or at least they were doing this you had
to text the cops and be like yo i'm
going to leave and they'd be like all
right you're good
or they'll be like no you can't leave
wow yeah man
that's living in high density you know
what i mean so if you look at
the weird thing about all of this you
look at europe and it's like
basically the size of the us but with
600 million people instead of 330
million people
and then you hear about places like
greece if you've ever been to france
it's really really dense in the big
cities
but it's just in the cities so why is it
affecting like
everybody why is like every everybody in
britain's
trapped you can't leave i wonder too
it's like can you go to northern ireland
and then if you go to northern ireland
can you drive into ireland and then once
you're in ireland are you
are you good this has been one of the
weirdest things about the uk i'm sure
people
in the uk and europe probably understand
better but
you know northern ireland is part of the
uk ireland is not
so and because of the treaty that the
foreign i don't know if it's the good
friday treaty or whatever
you there's there's not supposed to be
any border checkpoint between northern
ireland and
you know ireland so then how does that
work for
like the european union and this
lockdown could you just drive through
and then fly out yeah and then fly out
from like dublin or something or
whatever
i don't know what other island irish
cities are there probably helps to just
can you know do a lot of accents you
know you get stopped you're like
you tried
[Laughter]
what's that oh no i'm going to australia
oh no well it doesn't say australian
citizens
yeah so at what point do people kind of
like just lose their mind
maybe they go twerk yeah this is the
other side of that coin right
we talk about the the shutting down of
miami due to the twerking pandemic
and when you that that's like the people
saying enough and just twerking in the
streets
yeah but then in the uk it's the
opposite it's like the hardcore lockdown
maybe to stop people from having too
much fun
well i mean just from doing anything i
don't know so crazy
is the crazy thing about it is the the
the uh
kovid's survival rate yeah 99.95 for
ever for most people
97.5 for people over the age of 70. yet
they just shut down the entire country
you can't leave or they'll find you
that's weird almost the world they shut
down like almost the entire world
over this thing well i mean i unders
i i i get the pandemic stuff they're
like hey there's a pandemic so we gotta
restrict travel it's like it's like the
gameplay ink you know and the virus
happens like iceland shuts down and then
you're like oh we get in iceland and you
can't win the game then
but this is crazy this is them a year
later
shutting down their borders and not
letting anyone leave with a 99.95
percent yeah and then wasn't it like 60
percent
72 percent of people that have
contracted coveted were overweight or
obese
78 seven no who died of it right yeah
that's that's crazy man like i i would
feel weird
constricting travel only on obese people
that that feels wrong how about you can
go like obese people can travel
but only for going to the gym oh yeah
there you go they shut the gyms down
if you're going on a hike and you're
over certain you can't wait
no no no no no in the uk has been crazy
there was a video
where somebody was out in the middle of
nowhere early on in the pandemic and
they got stopped by a cop
and the cop was like what are you doing
outside and they're like i'm in the
middle of nowhere walking they're like
you're under arrest
and then there's another there's a viral
photo where the cops were like
think you're out for a stroll in the
middle of nowhere we'll find you
yeah no joke and people were like what
that's
creepy dude man they're they're locking
everybody in britain down that's what
happens you don't have a constitution
yeah they do right they have one but
it's not what is the parliamentary
constitution
it's an unwritten interpretable
vaguely understood quote unquote
constitution and the queen has
all the power at the end of the day she
just chooses not to exercise it
yeah she's quitting soon isn't she who
she giving power to who she's seeding
control to
i have no idea charles maybe i don't
know prince charles probably really good
for like single ladies who really want
to meet like a police officer boyfriend
so they just go out by themselves like
look really good like come get me
like me for vendetta like envy for
vendetta when uh
wasn't her name evie hammond it's nellie
portman she the the
they're called the finger men and they
stop her in the dark alley that's what
sounds good and they're gonna you know
try to abuse her
right the finger men that's what they're
called and then she's like oh no you're
a finger man i didn't know and then v
shows up and he does that speech where
every word is at the letter v
that movie's great by the way i'm just
wondering at what point
any of these people is gonna they're
gonna lose their minds and and do
something
to counter what the government's doing
because i mean there was a period where
there was a large group of british
subjects who got really angry
and then wrote this big thing to the
king like yo we're not british subjects
no more
yep and we've been doing all right over
here for some time
them over there they're not not going so
well it's crazy
and all this talk about like different
countries makes me realize how little
i've truly traveled in my life how where
have you gone
really just like italy france
uh canada briefly
i went to iceland only because it was
basically on sale like 10 years ago
like you'd see the ads like in new york
city mostly on the subway
please please come to iceland like we
know you're going somewhere else but can
you just like stop here on the
almost like a desperate like girlfriend
like please just come visit yeah they
had just like
overthrown their government and started
a new one
in 2008 this is the banking thing yeah i
went in 2008.
yeah no they had that what's that
airline they had an icelander
icelandic no it was a wow wow oh yeah
wow
and it was like are you going to spain
take wow air it stops for
you know three hours in iceland because
then they want you to spend money at the
airport shout out to iceland i mean they
really they actually overthrew
their corrupt banking and then like
seized control their government and
created a new more democratic
situation i don't know about that though
i think what people need to realize
about
these countries any one of these
countries particularly europe is
monoculture creates social enforcement
for anything they want
if you've got a tribalistic dogmatic
monoculture
then one person can act as a despot
because everyone just says okay to
whatever the machine is like you see it
with cancel culture
you know you get someone who's prominent
enough to
ignite or like light you know drop plant
that seed of some new idea and if
they're prominent enough people will
just latch onto it and then it works and
that social enforcement causes problems
for everybody what makes me nervous
about god save the queen man and i
really you guys in england i'm not
doing this it's not personal it just
terrifies me that there's this cult of
personality
surrounding your liege lord like it's
crazy that's true for everywhere with
kings bro
i know but people love their monarchs
some of them
i mean yeah but like when i was in do
you love the monarchy
when i was in thailand uh you know like
five was oh man like seven years ago now
when they were doing the whole
monarchist versus parliamentarian
protests
like even the people who were for like a
democratic process
with a prime minister would talk about
how amazing the king was
like he was a really good dude who
helped out people and used his power
properly
but it's time to move on that was really
interesting to me there were some people
who disparaged the monarchy for sure
but then they would always be like well
but we really do like the king because
he's kind of a cool guy
so like the king in thailand would use
resources to like help the poor and like
teach people to read and and do things
like that
so everyone was kind of just like oh
monarchy sucks but this guy's kind of
cool
but apparently nobody likes his son so i
don't know i'm not gonna pretend to be
an expert on thailand
yeah it's usually a bad king when it
falls apart king john of england was
when they forced the uh
what was that thing that made him sign
the magna carta basically seized control
from the
from the monarchy to a bunch of the
dukes and it was like the first step
towards democracy yeah magna carta was
pretty cool and then they had to duke it
out
yeah they did they literally had to sure
did etymology
yeah that's one way to put it dude get
out is that where it comes from
i imagine so yeah that's something like
that
put up your dukes yeah oh yeah huh
you're right was that what it is
it must be no it's gotta be get out of
here maybe
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you